The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
let's get started.
So today we're going to talk
about boundary value problems.
But I want to try to start
back with a motivating example.
So unfortunately, like
most technologies,
the biggest driver for
differential equation solutions
was from military technology.
And the military problem--
I'll tell you in a second.
Let me first remind you.
So we have ODE-IVPs.
And they are-- right.
So that's the ODE-IVP is we
have n differential equations,
and we have n
initial conditions.
And you guys are really
good at these now.
Had a lot of practice.
But you can have problems
where some of the conditions
are not specified at the t0.
They are specified
somewhere else.
So if all of them are specified
at t0, we call it an IVP.
And we call it a BVP is if
the conditions are like this.
This is not so good.
And not all the
tm's are the same.
If all the tm's are the
same, we call it t0,
and we're back to IVP.
So IVP is like a special
case of the ODE-BVP problem.
And here I'm ranking them as
if everything is explicit.
So we know an explicit
equation for dy dt.
We have an explicit equation
for the boundary conditions.
In fact, often, we actually
only have implicit equations.
So I'll show you an
example in a minute.
But that's it.
And we still need
to have n equations.
Well, I guess I could do this.
Take this back.
Basic goals, and just
be just be careful.
These ends are-- it's
the same number of them.
It's the same number
of conditions.
This is OK to write it this
way, but just be careful.
Is that OK?
Just to make it confusing.
All right.
I guess I can call this 0 now.
See, but now it's
not really 0, right?
It's really maybe-- call
it star at the boundary.
There's some special
value-- some special place
where you know the value of y.
All right.
So let's do the
motivating example, which
comes from military technology.
And this is quite
an old problem.
So, because, in the
old days, people
didn't have motor vehicles,
and, basically, the roads
were no good, and there
were a lot of bandits
out on the roads, people
liked to ship everything
by water transportation.
And so all the towns
grew up on rivers,
or on ports on the ocean.
And so, if you lived
in a nice little town,
you know, up in the
hills there, and then,
at the base of the hills, you
have your cute little town.
You have your house.
You have some warehouses where
you keep all your nice goods.
You have a dock that
goes out onto the water.
Here's the land.
Here, these nice ships
come and park at the dock.
They unload nice goods.
You trade your stuff to them.
You make a lot of money.
Everyone's happy and prosperous
and having a great time living.
This is a port city.
But then you look out on
the horizon in the water,
and you see a ship is coming.
And sometimes that
a ship is coming
is really good news for you.
But sometimes the ship coming
is not good because on the back,
it has a flag, and on the flag,
you see skull and crossbones.
And you realize it's
a pirate ship coming.
And now you're in
serious trouble
because you really don't
want the pirates to come
to your nice little
town because who
knows what they'll do there.
But it won't be good.
All right, so the people
who live in this town,
after this has happened
to you a few times,
you're really alarmed,
and you're really happy,
and you don't want to
rebuild your town again
because it just got
burned down the last time
and the pirate came and
pillaged it and took everything.
And you guys all had to
run away into the hills.
So instead, they've invented
cannons or catapults, put
one of the cannons, say,
at the top of the hill
above your town.
And then you say, the next
time the pirates come,
I'm ready for them.
So drawing the cannon.
And so the question is, you want
to shoot the cannonball so it
hit the pirate ship
at the waterline,
when the pirate is
distance L from the shore--
hopefully, pretty
far, so they're
not going to shoot at you first.
And you're shooting from
up at the top of the hill,
so you can shoot
further than they can.
So you're going to shoot
distance L. And you're
shooting from an
elevation H. And you
want to make sure your
cannonball hits them, ideally,
right at the waterline.
Boom, makes a nice hole in
their ship, and it sinks.
So that's the plan.
Now the problem is,
getting the cannonball
to go from here to
there is not so easy.
It's a big ocean.
There's a lot of places
your cannonballs can
fall into the ocean,
and it might not
be where the pirate ship is.
And reloading canon
is pretty slow.
And you guys live in
this prosperous port.
You're not military
guys, and so you
don't have that much
practice doing it anyway.
And you're cheap because
you're merchants.
And you don't want to
spend your money buying
lots of cannonballs anyway.
So you only get a few
of cannonballs up here.
And there's a little pile of
cannonballs next to the cannon.
And then, when you see
the pirate ship coming,
you guys run up the
hill quick, and you
get to take a couple of
shots, and that's it.
And if you hit them,
then your town is safe,
and, otherwise, everything you
love and know in your world
is going to be destroyed
by the pirates.
OK?
So this was the
motivating sample
for that element of
differential equation solvers.
OK?
So let's see if we can write
down the equations that
correspond to this example.
So it's going to
be Newton's laws.
F equals ma on the
cannonball as it travels.
So we can write that also as
equals-- well what's the F?
F is going to be negative
mg in the z direction.
That's gravity pulling
the cannonball down.
And then you'll have some air
friction on the cannonball.
And I'm going to call the air
friction coefficient gamma m
times v. OK?
So that's the simplest
model for what
the forces are on a cannonball
just flying from my cannon,
hopefully, to hit
the pirate ship.
And I can rearrange us
by dividing through by m.
And acceleration is velocity,
so dv dt is equal to negative g.
So you have negative gamma--
sorry.
My notation is not so good.
OK.
Everyone is all right with this?
Yeah.
So then we can write the whole
differential equation system,
d dt of xz vx vz equals
dx dt is vx, dz dt is vz.
dvx dt is negative gamma vx.
dvz dt is negative
g minus gamma v ez.
So that's a fine ODE system.
It's not too hard to solve.
It's actually linear.
It's a piece of cake, right?
You guys just probably
just did this already
when you were in high school,
or college, anyway, for sure.
And let's write down
the initial conditions.
So we know x0 is equal to 0.
z of 0 is equal to h,
the height of the canon.
vx of 0, oh, what's
that equal to?
We don't know. vz of 0,
we don't know that either.
But we bought this canon with
a certified muzzle velocity v0,
so we actually know
that vx of 0 squared
plus the vz of 0 squared
is equal to v0 squared--
whereas, when I
bought the canon,
the merchants went out
to the local canon dealer
and bought a canon,
and the guy said,
you put this much
gunpowder in it,
you'll get a muzzle
velocity of v0.
So they know that
that number is.
So we have a condition
that's not really the way
we expect it to be.
And we don't have
enough conditions.
We need four conditions.
But of course, the most
important condition
is what happens at L. We really
want to know that x of t final
is equal to L and y of t final
is equal to 0 at sea level.
So that way, our
cannonball is going to
into the right
location at t final.
So we have two
conditions specified way,
way away from where we are.
And we have two conditions
specified initially.
And no you have
some oddball thing
in here, some oddball
fifth condition.
Now, OK.
One problem here is,
we don't actually
know what t final is
because before we shoot it,
we really don't know how
long it takes the cannonball
to get out there.
So this is a kind
of weird condition
where t final is unknown,
whereas, the ones you've
done before, I think you've
always known t final.
Is that right?
So let's talk about
how to deal with that.
So one problem, one
way to deal with this
is to notice that, if we have
an equation system dy dt equals
f of y, we could change
variables instead of using t.
Since we really don't know much
about time in this problem,
t is not the best
variable for us.
So we want to change it
to some new variable u.
So suppose that we
want to change to u.
And, if we change to u,
we can write something
like this-- dy du
du dt equals f of y.
Can you see that?
So I can try to get the
differentials in terms of u,
and I just have to
know what my du dt is.
And you guys might have
even changed the variables
before, in calculus sometime,
you probably did this--
a long time ago, and chain
rule, and stuff like that.
All right, so we can sort of
pick whatever idea we want,
and as long as we put in
the du dt in the equation,
then we'll be OK.
So let's just choose that u is
equal to x because we know du
dt would then be with the vx.
So we could we could
write this out this way.
We could write d--
I'll keep it as u for a
minute, so the notation
won't be so confusing.
So du dt, dy du is equal
to f of y over du dt.
And as long as du dt is
never zero, we're good.
So we could any u we want
as long du dt is never zero.
Then we're still going to have
a nice simple question here.
And so I'm going to choose u is
equal to x because du dt is vx.
And I know that
vx is never zero.
They're kind of also
always moving to the right.
So I'm going to
divide by something.
It's never zero.
So I can write it this way--
dy du is equal to--
I can go down that list and
divide each of these things
by vx.
So it's 1, vz over vx,
negative gamma, negative g
over vx minus gamma vz over vx.
That's my new [INAUDIBLE].
OK?
OK with this?
How about energetic?
Keep nodding.
Yeah, yeah, sure,
keep going faster.
It's going way too slow.
That's what I want you to say.
Yeah?
Apparently not.
OK.
All right.
So the advantage
to changing here
is that now I can write the
initial conditions, and all
these conditions, in
terms of u, which is x.
So I really-- I want to go
from u is equal to 0, i.e.
X is equals to 0, to u is equal
to L, which is x equal to L.
So now, I could also
look at this say,
this is kind of stupid. dy
du, the first component of y
is dy du is equal to one.
And that first
component of y never
appears in the rest
of these equations.
So that's kind of not
a very useful one.
So I can change, and I could
write a simpler equation,
dy tilde du is equal to vz over
vx negative gamma, negative g
over vx minus gamma
vz over vx, where
my y tilde is just equal to
the last three variables--
z, vx, vz.
So I did a lot of
algebra, but I ended up
simplifying my
life because now I
have three different equations
to solve instead of four.
And I can write
that y tilde of zero
of the first element of y tilde,
which is z, is equals to h.
So that's a condition
I know for sure.
And I know that I really
want this cannonball
to hit the pirate ship.
So I want y1 tilde of L to
be 0, so I want tilde as z.
And I want z to be 0
when x is equal to L.
Or that's the point where the
cannonball is hitting the ship
at the water line there.
So those are definitely
two conditions I have.
And then I need a
third condition.
And my third condition is
this crazy equation here.
All right, so now I
have three conditions
for three differential
equations, and one of them
is an oddball looking thing.
These two look kind of normal.
However, this one is
a t0, and this one
is some goofball value, but
at least I know the value.
I know what L is
because I know how far
away the pirate ship is.
So far so good?
All right.
But how am I going
to solve this?
So how do we know how to solve
differential equations right
now is we know how to do
initial value problems.
We have these nice
programs like ode45
that work great, integrate
differential equations.
So we should be able to use
that somehow to solve this.
But we don't have all
the inputs because ode45
would expect us to give
values of all three of the y
tilde values at 0.
I only know one of them.
So how can I approach it?
Sorry, I'm going to put
my beautiful drawing
down below here.
We'll save it for posterity
and look at it later.
So I could approach
it by saying, well,
I don't know what these two
initial conditions would be,
what vx and vz should be at 0.
I'll treat them as unknowns.
I want to figure out
what they should be.
And so, I'm going to
vary those unknowns
and then, for each
value I choose,
then I can shoot the cannon
with those v's, and I
can see where the
cannonball went,
and if it didn't go
to the right location,
I can readjust those
v's and then try again.
Just like, if you were
running the cannon,
you might shoot at
a certain angle,
and then adjust the angle of the
cannon, and then shoot again.
And then, when you
change the angle,
you change the ratio of
vx to vy initially, right?
So that's called the
shooting method--
for good reason.
So the shooting method,
that's what we do.
We guess the missing
initial conditions,
then you solve using the guess.
You solve the ODE-IVP problem.
And then you see
what it computes.
And if the solution
you get doesn't
satisfy the
conditions you demand,
you go back and
adjust your guess.
And you loop around.
So that's the idea.
Now, this thing
of adjusting some
parameter values, some
initial conditions,
to try to satisfy
some condition, that's
like an f solve problem.
That's a system of nonlinear
equations kind of problem.
So we're going to have f
solve as the outside loop,
and that's going to
adjust some parameters.
And then, what's f solve do?
So f solve tries to solve
problems of the form g of--
I usually write x, but
I'll call it v here.
No.
V's not good either.
What letter have we
have not used yet?
Any letter.
g of w.
There we go.
g of w equals 0.
I want to figure out
what w's I need to use.
And actually, v is right.
Because we're trying to
adjust the velocities, right?
Sorry, I'm messing up here.
It's good to use the
eraser in this class--
especially with this
nice big eraser.
All right, so g of e--
we're trying to adjust the
velocities to make something 0.
So what's our g that we want?
We really want that
the z value at L--
we want that to be equal to 0.
And this thing is, like,
implicitly a function
of the v's--
the v0 values we give.
If you put the right v0 values
in, then z at L would be 0.
So this is what we're
really trying to solve.
Now, to get z of L, we have to
solve a system of differential
equations.
So it's a little complicated
to go from v0 to zL,
but we can do because
we have ode45.
So we can write a
function to do this.
Running out of words.
All right so let's try
to write the program.
So we want to write
the program g.
So we want to write z of
L is equal to g of v0.
And let's try to think
what this function is.
So the meat of this is, we
have to solve a differential
equation, an IVP.
So somewhere, we
have an ode45 call.
And what does ode45 computing?
It's computing the x
positions and the z positions.
And it's going to use some
function f, which was--
do we still have
it on the board?
Maybe I lost it here.
Nope.
Sorry, it's under here.
I'm a terrible board worker.
So this is our
function f, f f of y.
So this is really f tilde.
That's the function that
I'm going to integrate.
And I can't remember
what are the arguments,
but it's going to be
something like, from 0 to L,
and then I have to give it
a y0, and then maybe there's
some other stuff up there.
All right, do you guys
remember the ode45?
Is that in the right order?
I don't remember.
OK.
So I need to specify the y0.
So y0 is going to be equal
to the initial value of z,
the altitude.
So it's going to be H. And then
it's the initial value of vx.
So I don't know what
that is, but it's--
maybe you just
want to call it v0.
vx0.
And then I do have one
more condition here,
that vz is related to vx.
So I can use that.
So I can have the last one be
the square root of v0 squared
minus vx0 squared.
So that's the line
for what y0 is.
And then I solve this.
And then I write the
number of steps in the time
stepping program that
did, in order to get here.
It was x stepping in this case.
Num steps is equal to
the length of x vec.
And z of L is equal
to z vec at N step.
That's it, right?
So that's the function that
you would feed to f solve.
And your correct
value of vx 0 is
the one that makes zL 0, which
is what f solve tried to do.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You can, but
in the physical problem,
usually cannons
always shoot upwards.
So we'll just shoot upwards.
But yeah, it could
be either way.
Yeah, and, in fact,
in this problem,
you might do better to
change-- instead of using vx0
as your unknown, you might want
to change to theta, the angle,
the elevation angle
of the cannon,
and that would be more physical
of what the actual user
of the cannon is using.
They're adjusting theta,
not adjusting vx0.
It's no problem, actually.
From the point of
view of the f solves,
you can make this theta instead.
And then you'd have this
be v0 times cos of theta,
and this b v0 times
sine of theta,
and it would work just as
well to get the solution.
All right, so that's
the shooting method.
So this function
g is the g that's
going-- you'll have f
solve, so is going to say,
vx0 is equal to f solve of g.
And then you have to
have a guess, right?
For f solve.
So that's how you would
invoke this function.
All right, and so if
we wanted to figure
operation count of
how many operations
this is to find a solution
this way, how's it go?
How many iterations does it
take to solve an ODE IVP.
That depends on the
step size, right?
It's adaptive.
Usually adaptive stepping.
So you have some experience
with that, maybe 100 steps?
Something like that?
Is usually enough?
Maybe 1,000 if it's not stiff?
And then how many
iterations does it take
f solve to solve something?
10?
So you have maybe 1,000 time
steps, maybe 10 iterations,
means 10 different
initial values
that you try before you
convert to a solution.
And then you may have
to actually compute
the Jacobian of
g, inside f solve,
if it's going to use
the Newton-Raphson step,
it's going to need
the Jacobian of g.
The Jacobian of g
takes the number
of unknowns times the number
of function evaluations
to compute it by finite
differences-- maybe 2 times
that number.
So it's going to be
something like n squared.
It'll be n squared to
evaluate the Jacobian.
It takes n operations
to evaluate f.
So order of n, where n is
the number of variables,
n times that, to the Jacobian,
so it would be like order
of number variables squared
times 10 times 1,000 is
kind of an order of the cost.
And it's only that cost because
we can do an explicit solver.
If you had to do an
implicit ODE solution,
it would be a lot
more because you'd
have to compute the
Jacobians more often.
All right.
Is this fun?
OK.
So this is the shooting method.
You guys should be able
to do this no trouble.
Conceptually, this is not so
different than the homework
problem you did where you did
an optimization of the parameter
values.
Do you remember?
So you had some
differential equations,
and you optimize the
parameters to try
to find the best solutions.
Here, instead of optimizing
them, you're doing f solve.
You're trying to solve them
to make something happen.
Now how can this
run into troubles.
Why would this shooting
method not always work?
Ready why this might not work?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: And a common
case where that might happen
would be if your ODE
system was unstable,
Or your ODE solution method
was numerically unstable.
In either of those cases, who
knows what you're getting.
And actually, you don't know
if the solution is even real.
You don't know if the
computed final values
zL is really what corresponds
to that input value of vx0.
Because, if you have a big
kind of numerical sensitivity
and instability.
So that's one kind of problem.
So this is just like all
the ODE IVP problems.
If the ODE's problem,
intrinsically,
is unstable in a big
way, you're in trouble
because your errors
are going to amplify.
And then also, if you have
a problem where the delta
t's are too large compared
to this numerical stability
of the solver, you'll
also have a problem.
So those are two kinds of
problems that we always
have in ODE solutions.
And so, you might
actually want to use
this method for some
regular ODE IVP problems.
So for example, if
you had a problem--
I don't want to wreck
my beautiful artwork.
You guys know this.
All right.
If you had a problem that
said dy dt is equal to 10
to the 6th times y.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the Jacobian.
When you calculate
the Jacobian do you
have to solve the ODE system?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Well, two ways.
You can either solve
it for repeated values,
different initial values, of
v0, and by finite difference,
get the Jacobian.
Or you could use the
sensitivity method
that we did in the second
problem, a problem set ago,
and analytically get the
derivatives without respect
to the parameters either way.
But either way,
it's a lot of work.
So the from I guess this
is a very simple problem,
and suppose you wanted to go
all the way out to t equals 1.
Now, the problem is that the
solution of this is Ae times 10
to the 6th times t or something.
So this is really
not looking so great.
As a problem to solve,
this is about as unstable
as you can get.
The tiniest little deviation
anywhere along the way
is going to make
the thing blow up.
And so this is not
so great and so even
if initial condition is
that y of t0 is equal to 10
to the minus 12, so
actually this is not so bad,
this is still hard to
solve, numerically.
But you could flip it
around, and treat it
as a shooting problem,
and solve it in reverse.
So you could change variables
that u is equal to negative t.
And then you'd have dy du
is equal to negative 10
to the 6 times y.
And now this is really stable.
And now you might
want to integrate in.
So supposed the
original question was,
what is y of 1 in the
differential equations?
You could do it in reverse and
say, I'm going to guess, y of 1
is equal to y guess.
And I'm going to integrate
it and demand that this
is my final condition.
So now this is actually y--
oh geez, now I'm
confusing myself.
y of negative 1, I guess.
So I just flipped the sign, t.
And to make it easier,
I would do it this way.
1 minus t.
Same derivative.
So there we go. y0 is y guess.
And y of 1 is 10
to the minus 12.
So this is my final condition
that I'm trying to shoot to,
and I'll vary the y guess.
And they're great.
And now I have a perfectly
stable differential equation
I can solve.
OK.
So this same idea
of shooting comes up
in multiple applications.
And this whole thing
about flipping the change
in the variables is often
an extremely useful trick
to just recast the equations in
a way that's more numerically
stable to solve, has
fewer number of equations,
you can write explicitly
what you want.
But this takes some cleverness
to know how to recast them.
All right, so this motivating
example is a good one.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You
could, but I was just
trying to get back in the
form of t0 equals zero.
I guess I could have t0
equals negative 1 do it.
I just couldn't do the
arithmetic on the board.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: y of 0
is known, but then I
have to start from
t0 equals negative 1.
So I could do--
so suppose I did u
equals negative t dy
du is equal to
negative 10 to the 6 y.
And I know y of 0
is equal to to--
no, what do I know?
Yeah, y of 0 is equal
to 10 to the minus 12.
And y of negative 1
is equal to y yes,
and I can integrate
from negative 1 over.
So this will t0 if I was
using the shooting method,
and this would be t final.
Or you could shift it
over by 1 if you want,
and do it the way I did.
Either one's fine.
Is that all right?
Sorry to confuse
all the arithmetic.
I was getting confused too.
All right, now I wrote this--
another situation where
this will not work
is you can have
systems where you
have both positive and negative
eigenvalues of the Jacobian,
and that means that
either way you integrate--
in the plus t direction or
the negative t direction,
either way it's always unstable.
So no matter what you
do, you're doomed.
The IVP method is not going to
work because you're numerically
unstable in both directions.
And so that's really
a bummer, and it
means our ODE IVP method's
not going to work for us,
and so then we have to
find a different method.
But before I go into
that, let's just write
the more general
version of this.
OK, so this is--
I think you guys all know this.
So let's try a more general
version of the ODE IVP problem.
And now we'll allow for
the fact that things
don't have to be
explicit, and they have
to be as simple as we thought.
And you can see it even
in the problem I just
did-- we had a vx squared
plus vz squared had
to be equal to something.
And so that's not a
simple boundary condition
like we saw before.
So you get a more
complicated conditions,
and what you really can
have is a set of equations,
gn of dy dt y, t,
and is equal to 0.
And corresponding, qn of dy
dt evaluated at tn, y of tn,
tn is equal to 0.
So this is the
general ODE system
that's written in
implicit form, and this
has to be true for
all t in the domain.
All t that are a
member of t0 to tf.
So all the t's that are inside
this interval, the domain we
are about, this is the
differential equation, written
as just as general
can be, and n is
equal to 1 and N
in these equations.
AUDIENCE: Is there a reason you
switched to q of n for the--
PROFESSOR: I just
want to make it clear
that this is the conditions, and
this is the general equation.
I don't know.
You can write it
anyway you want.
Do you like some variable
letters instead of q?
I can change this.
AUDIENCE: No, I
was just checking.
PROFESSOR: This one, I'm
just trying to emphasize.
This one is only
true at tn only.
This equation, this
is the condition
at one particular time I
demand something be true,
and this is the general
difference equation that
has to be true at all times.
If I have n differentials, I
need n differential equations,
and n initial conditions.
By the way, you can write
the DAEs this way as well--
the differential algebraic
equations, and then
you just won't have as
many initial conditions
because every time you have
an algebraic equation instead
of a differential
equation, then you
don't need the initial condition
because the algebraic equation
has its own condition.
Does that make sense?
All right, so you can write
this in general, and just
by depending on how many
differentials you have,
that's how many
conditions you need.
A lot of times, you can
write them explicit.
This thing is equivalent to
dy dt is equal to f of ty.
Many times, you can solve for
dy dt, and write this way,
but not always.
OK All right, and the reason
why we need to have n conditions
is just like when
you're doing integrals,
you'd have n constants
of integration.
Every time you do an
integral, you get one,
now you have three.
We have n differential
equations.
We'll have n conditions.
All right?
Now, a bad thing about
these problems, in general,
is that the solutions depend a
lot on the boundary conditions.
And in fact, you can write
down boundary conditions
that are not achievable, which
means there's no solution.
So this is really
a bummer if you
don't realize you did it because
you could try to solve it
all day, and you'll
never solve it because it
doesn't have a solution.
So for example, in this problem,
if I set L to be too large,
the cannonball
can't go that far.
I can't set L to
be 3,000 kilometers
and get a solution because
the muzzle velocity is not
high enough that the
cannonball is going
to travel 3,000 kilometers.
But when I wrote the problem,
you didn't see that, right?
You didn't come and tell
me, whoa, watch out.
There's no way L could be
bigger than such as such.
And so you might not know it.
You might specify a condition
that's just not achievable.
I used to work an industry,
this happened a lot.
My manager would specify
boundary conditions
which were not achievable.
I want 99% yield and
a 10% cost reduction.
Go!
And I'm the engineer, I'm
trying to work it out,
and then sometimes it
didn't even come out.
So in some ways, it's a
lot better to just say max.
Please maximize this
as best you can,
subject to your constraints,
instead of specifying this.
But of course, I don't
know why, there's
a school of management that says
we weren't definite targets.
We don't want to be just the
best, we want to be perfect.
So the no child left behind.
Every single student
in this class
is going to really achieve.
Anyway, that's the
way targets gets set.
It doesn't have
to be achievable.
And there's actually
a big branch
of mathematics about trying
to detect if the boundary
conditions are indeed consistent
so that they can be achieved,
and it's not so
obvious to do it.
So I'm not going to
get into that at all.
You can take a PDE class.
There's a math
department, and that's
all they talk about all day
is about how to figure out
are these boundary conditions
consistent or not consistent.
You also have
boundary conditions
that are repetitive, and
don't have enough information.
In those cases, you might
have an infinite number
of solutions.
And I think you can
also have cases where
you have multiple solutions.
So like in the
cannonball problem,
if you could have a negative
vy, and if the ship was
close enough, you might be
able to shoot it two ways.
You can shoot it down at it,
or you could just blow up high
and come down, and they'll
both be solutions that
satisfy all the conditions.
This is like general
non-linear equation problems,
that you don't know how
many solutions you got,
you don't know if
you have a solution,
you might have an infinite
number of solutions,
you might have some finite
you don't know
how many, and it's
just that's the way life is,
and you'll have to live with it.
But it's kind of
annoying sometimes.
For now, let's just assume
that we somehow know
that we have a unique solution.
There's a unique
physical solution.
We're just going to
try to find that,
and we're not going to worry
about this other problem
about the fact
there could actually
be multiple solutions, or
no solution, or whatever.
When you actually run
into a case like that,
then you'll really
worry about it a lot.
Is there a question?
No?
OK.
All right, so we had
an example in actually
the zeroth homework,
the very beginning,
that had a problem like this.
The homework 0P1, we had a
problem where it gave you--
Do you remember this?
It was a cylinder, and you
were trying to compute t of r.
Do you remember this?
And it gave you some
conditions about here.
It gave you t when r w was equal
to r, and it gave you dt dr--
actually, it gave
you some equation.
It was actually a function of
this and t, all evaluated at r.
It was equal to something.
Do you remember this?
So we gave those
two, but then we also
told you in the most recent
homework, oh, by the way,
dt dr has got to be
equal to 0 at r equals 0.
So this is one of these
ones where we should only
have two conditions, but we
told you three conditions.
So were any of you able to
achieve all three conditions?
No.
OK, so this is
highlighting the problem.
So we gave you three
boundary conditions
that were apparently
incompatible,
that you couldn't actually
solve them all at the same time.
So beware, I guess.
Now, in that problem,
it might have
been more natural to give
you this equation, which
we are sure is exactly true by
the symmetry of the situation
as one of the
conditions, and then only
one of these other
conditions outside.
That whichever one we were
more sure was correct,
might be the thing to do.
And so we kind of gave you
some goofball conditions.
I guess, in some ways.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So if all three of
those conditions are true,
why wouldn't they
converge to a solution?
PROFESSOR: They
could all be true,
and if they were all
true, then if you
solve the numerical exactly, you
should get the real solution.
It should satisfy all of them.
AUDIENCE: So does
that mean one of them
wasn't true in our case?
If we weren't able to do--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I think
one of them wasn't true,
and I think it's maybe
due to round off.
But it's highlights a problem.
If you have three conditions
that should be true,
but they involve
numbers in them,
then often they
won't all be exactly
consistent with each other.
But there's actually a
worse kind of problem
because it's close to
being consistent to all
of those conditions, but
you're not exactly consistent.
But then if you
get into it, trying
to figure what's going
on, a lot of times
you'll get near singular
matrices and stuff
because you have things
that are nearly linearly
dependent in some way.
So really, it's
better if you just
have the right number of
conditions that you're
really sure really specify
everything correctly, and just
go with those, and treat
the ones that you think
would be nice if they were
true as approximate things that
are sort of physical checks to
see whether your solution is
reasonable.
And we did it sort of like
that in the problem you did.
We said well, dt dr should
really be equal to 0,
but we didn't demand
that in your solution.
Your solution didn't
actually satisfy that,
and we use that as a measure of
how far off your solution is.
That's actually pretty
useful in practice.
You get a solution.
It's good to have some
additional condition
that you can test for physical
reasonableness of the solution,
and particularly because there's
a problem that you might have
multiple solutions,
and maybe one of them
is a physical solution,
and one of them
is some other crazy solution.
And so you need to
have some way to detect
the crazy solution by some other
condition that you can test.
Does that make sense?
All right, so I said you
could have cases where
the Jacobian of your equation--
so you could be trying to
solve this, and it could be,
for some problems
the Jacobian always
has both positive and
negative eigenvalues together.
And in that case,
using IVP is not
going to be a smart idea because
no matter which direction you
integrate in, you're going to
have a positive eigenvalue,
and so then the IVP is not good.
So instead, we're going
to use a different method,
and we'll talk about
that next time,
and those are called
relaxation methods.
And the concept of
these is different
than it was for shooting.
So the relaxation method is you
have a wide guess that you're
going to have a guess
for the entire y
throughout the whole domain.
Actually, a lot of
times you might set this
up so that y guess
actually exactly
satisfies the
boundary conditions.
So you know it satisfies
those equations right
from the beginning just from
the way you set up y guess,
but it won't satisfy the
differential equation.
And then what you'll
do is you'll say
how badly does it fail to
satisfy that g is equal to 0?
Because we really want g is
equal 0 for the true solution.
And we'll call this failure
of our y guess to solve this,
we'll call that the residuals.
So we can actually plug
in y guess in here,
and y guess in here,
and evaluate this.
And normally it will
not be 0 because our y
guess is not perfect, and so
it's going to deviate from 0.
But how big it
deviates from 0 is
going to be our measure
of how bad that guess was,
and then we're going
to try to change
y guess to try to make it
closer and closer to 0.
So the idea is relax it.
You get an incorrect
solution, and you
adjust it to relax it to make
it become the correct solution.
All right, and so that's the
general idea of the relaxation
method, and we'll talk about
several different forms
of that.
Normally, what we
have to do is you
have to write y guess in
terms of some parameters.
So y guess of t depends
on some parameters,
and we're going
adjust the parameters,
and that's going to
change what y guess is.
And so for example, we could
do a basis set expansion
as we did in one of
the earlier classes.
We talked about how
you could expand
y guess as a sum of some basis
functions weighted by p's, and
then you can adjust
the p's, and find
the best possible set of p's
to make this g as close to 0
as possible, for example.
We'll give examples
of that next time.
There's several choices
about that there.
All right.